penelope your mother talking of children
uh your mother she what did she run a
was it a hair salon or a beauty salon
yeah um that beauty salon yeah actually
that was like my first acting school
because i would sit in front of the
women and my mother pretending to be
doing my homework but behind my books i
was just spying and observing all these
women confessing to my mother their
secrets
and
it was fascinating for me their behavior
i don't know it was i really consider it
my first acting school but you got
skills as well i mean you do hair don't
you i i tried to cut every everybody's
hair anyone who let me i would cut their
hair or penelope you can cut my head
have you have you ever done pedro's no
no he doesn't lit me
no why didn't you let her cut your hair
because the last time she cuts it look
like this
lionel
but is it true your good friend salma
hayek you do her hair
no one i am very close to her one time
she called me and said the lights are
off in my house and also the makeup
artist and the hairdresser cannot come
and i have a premiere in two hours so
come and do it in the dark
the candles do the hair the makeup she
was happy with the result so
but but also you do beauty treatments
not just haircuts you do treatments oh
that's because you know that i washed
her legs once when we were in mexico
yes is there video evidence of this or
and if you know how to do it you do it
to your friends do you know what i'm
saying yeah yeah
i know i'd do it i'm gonna do it to my
friend yeah help a sister out yeah
[Music]